you
this technology has been used in a wide
variety of fields I know like it has an
application in manufacturing and but the
way that we as a club order line uses AR
it's basically to kind of reveal a
second meaning or hidden layer behind
the student murals the way that it works
is you see this animation playing on
your phone through the app that we use
it can reveal something that previously
wasn't there one day I just realized
that this because of this kind of desire
to know these microorganisms better um I
used to turn empathy Academy empathize
with the bacteria that is constituting
me in a very mature and literate way and
then I suddenly realized that I would
never reach that that state of empathy
with my bacteria in the petri dish
because then it's it's a specimen and
it's specifying itself as a specimen and
I'm in that power dynamic in that
relationship that would never constitute
something close to empathy or wonder or
surprise because the object is already
known
there's a way that data is kind of
treated as as found material it's just
kind of out there but you know it's not
exactly the same as you know just
picking something up off the street it's
something that's usually highly
integrated into people's lives and
that's so there's these like questions
of consents and power that are baked in
and I think that's where they converge
for me being an artist and being a
creative at it might be also like
understanding the ethics and
implications of the technologies that we
use the technologies would create and
the technologies that are at our service
let's say for creation so for example
yeah like this light microgravity
flights they consume a lot of like image
a amounts of fossil fuel for example
there's number of next year to emissions
out of these experiments and then it
makes us wonder and putting a balance
what what does it mean right and what
does it mean do is the work that we're
doing are the questions that were asking
a relevant enough to also be inter
balanced and make like an equilibrium a
in these perspectives that we need to be
wondering about that we need to be
creating with